there are three landing pages that we
use most commonly which is headline sub
headline content info submit same thing
except with an image same thing with an
image and then three bullets those are
the three most common layouts I use pick
one of them and all you got to do is
test it and the nice thing is the
simpler the landing page the fewer
variables you have to test you can
quickly improve it it also gives the
person who's clicking to that page fewer
things to do they said they wanted the
thing they go to the page the page says
here's the thing you said you wanted
they're like yeah I guess I did want it
and they submit and then you get super
high conversion rates the more steps you
get someone or ask someone to go through
the fewer people will do it but the more
qualified the leads will be so there's
going to be a balance there if you get
too many leads then add some
qualification steps if you get too few
leads remove some